[Musique]
stanley et mia fui la grisaille et
partent en floride
et tant qu'à y être il loue une
décapotable on leur suggère de protéger
le véhicule avec une assurance collision
il accepte à fort prix sauf que le
couple ignore qu'il est déjà couvert par
sa propre assurance automobile
comme de nombreux canadiens pour moment
d'assurer leur voiture ils ont adhéré à
l'avenant 27
un avenant c'est un ajout aux contrats
d'assurance et lorsqu'on conduit un
véhicule qui ne nous appartient pas
comme la décapotable l'avenant 27 couvre
les dommages à ce véhicule
et cela s'applique aussi aux états unis
très pratique pour les escapades avec
une voiture louée
mais attention hein il faut choisir une
voiture d'une valeur pas plus élevée que
celle prévue dans l'avenant et la valeur
et en dollars canadiens 2 on recommande
d'augmenter votre montant en
responsabilité civile à au moins 2
millions de dollars c'est plus prudent
le fin mot de l'histoire
vous allez ailleurs prendre l'air
vérifiez que votre assureur couvrez vos
arrières